900 مليون دولار مبلغ ضخم في عالم كره
القدم صحيح لكنه يتضاءل بجانب القدم
اليسرى لميسي هذا الرقم الفلكي هو قيمه
تامين الاسطوره الارجنتيني على قدمه
اليسرى فهذه القدم كانت وما زالت تداعب
الكره تتحكم في مشاعر المشجعين
وتقصوا دائما على المنافسين لكن اذا اصيبت
قدم ميسي فهناك امور كثيره ستحدث
حتما سيتئثر الفريق وربما سيغضب الجمهور
والاكيد هنا هو خساره شركه التامين
ميسي يتصدر قائمه اغلى اقدام في العالم
بتامين يصل الى 900 مليون دولار
متفوقا على رونالدو الذي يمتلك بوليصه
تامين على قدمه تقدر بنحو 144 مليون دولار
وبتوضيح اكثر قيمه قدم ميسي تعادل اضعاف
قيمه قدم رونالدو بل ان 900 مليون دولار
قد تكون اغلى من قيمه منتخبات بعينها في
مونديال 2022
فهذه القيمه تقترب من القيمه التسويقيه
للمنتخب الفرنسي ب 904 ملايين دولار
وتزيد على قيمه المنتخب البرتغالي البالغه
892 مليون دولار
والمنتخب الاسباني البالغه
818 مليون دولار
الفيفا تلزم الاتحادات المحليه بتوفير
تامين طبي للاعبين خلال مشاركتهم مع
منتخبات بلادهم وفي حاله تعرض اللاعب
لاصابه اثناء تمثيله المنتخب بلاده يتم
تعويض الانديه ولان ميسي يلعب في الدوري
الفرنسي فهناك نوع من التامين المهني
بالاصابات الخطيره التي تتسبب بابتعاد
اللاعب عن الميدان لاكثر من ثلاثه اشهر
ولو ثبت ان اهمال اللاعب ادى الى تسبب
بالاصابه تقع عليه غرامه الماليه ويحرم من
راتبه
بسهوله ربما بسبب مرونته الشديده في
التعامل مع التدخلات العنيفه وقد تساعده
في ذلك نوعيه الاحذيه التي يرتديها على
العشب الاخضر
حذاء ميسي هذا صنع من ماده تمنع الانزلاق
عند الكعب بالاضافه لمزودات السرعه وتصميم
يساعد على مرونه الحركه وتغيير الاتجاهه
هذا الحذاء يحمل اسماء اكس ميسي 2022 وهو
مستوى حامل حذاء اديداس اف 30 الذي ارتداه
في اول كاس عالم شارك بها عام 2006
ظاهره تامين على القدم لا تقتصر على نجوم
الساحره المستدير فهناك عدد من النجمات
وقعنا عقود تامين على اقدامهم
احداهن مغنيه الابل الامريكيه تايلور سويف
التي اتجهت لتامين على ركبتيه ساقيها بنحو
اربعين مليون دولار